our next question is from Riley in st.
Louis my name is Riley Brown I am 20
years old and I live in st. Louis
Missouri congratulations on your 100th
episode and I hope you come visit my
town again my question for you is how
can I better shine light on my
essentialist lifestyle as I'm getting
older my family is growing more and more
non supportive of the changes I choose
to make with Who I am
everything from Ivan's been removed to
Matt for my life too
I will react to situations to constantly
refuting my mission in life I feel like
they undermined and deny Who I am
because they want me to become as they
are now how can I help them see that I
am my own person pursuing my own path
and only wish to be accepted thank you
very much had a great day so Ryan I was
reminded of two essays that are on our
website that we wrote one of them
together and then I wrote this one
recently about unsolicited discharge now
I'm not sure if this is exactly what
Riley is getting I sort of wrote this
about criticism but he's certainly
getting some criticism before I read a
little bit of this though she said
something that was fascinating to me she
said how do i shine a light on my
minimalist lifestyle and I think
something is important to realize there
there's light above us right so yeah a
spotlight almost right now there's a
thing there's a good and bad side of
shining a light on something because
because you can see my dry skin in the
corner of my temples here and it brings
out all the flaws right yeah light you
have that scar on your forehead and I
can definitely see that scar on your
forehead right now I think it makes you
more beautiful thank you now the but
they call me Frankenstein in grade
school so so one thing to think about
here if you're trying to shine the light
just keep in mind that you're also going
to illuminate the flaws now the good
thing is you'll actually see what to
improve as well and by shining the light
so you and I we have written a lot about
our own lives we've talked about our own
lives Allah we've done videos and
documentary about our own
lives our lives are out there we've
signed the light on our lives yeah and
it's helped me really understand and
come to terms but also it's really
difficult that last little segment a
podcast Shawn's tearing up in the corner
over there where you're talking about
your relationship with your father and I
think it's gonna help a lot of people
but shining the light on that is also
really difficult and it's hard to talk
about and quite often we don't want to
confront these issues for real we we
think we do but realize that if you're
going into battle with some of these
issues it's actually going to be a
battle now in in terms of of dealing
with their undermining and their not
being supportive and you want to help
them understand I thought about this
essay unsolicited discharge or put a
link to in the show notes but this goes
a little something like this it's really
sure last week Ryan and I filmed a
living room conversation on our YouTube
channel about dealing with criticism
well I agree with everything we said I'd
like to add a few words there is a
significant difference between feedback
and criticism we must seek feedback from
trusted people because it makes our work
and our life better right you know
feedback in fact yesterday we were in
the process of hiring a filmmaker for
the minimalists and what we did is we we
got in a room we got with the 19
different finalists we were watching
their their their videos their
submissions their reels but then we we
narrowed it down to a top seven and we
sent the top seven to our trusted
friends we wanted feedback from people
like mad and and I sent it to Bex and
and today yeah exactly and so we got and
Jess Jessica provided feedback and and
so we got feedback from all of these
these different people because feedback
helps us understand what we're missing
gives us a clean pair of eyes and it's
important it's always they're not gonna
agree with us but that's a good thing
right
yeah man it well criticism is so
important man it's so important here's
the thing I think feedbacks important I
like to die I I know it sounds like
semantics but I like to differentiate
for me feedback provides the problem
with a solution most criticism I think
about I just
this world criticism it just highlights
the problem and they're like um look at
that scar on his forehead
yeah youtube comment we'll see we'll see
that's where I differentiate that's not
that's not criticism that is discharge
exactly so so for me when I say
criticism is important I think criticism
can be part of feedback I don't think
they're you know interchangeable words
but I think criticism is is a piece of
that
I think criticism is important because
none of us are perfect and any of us who
walk around I think that we have it
figured out 100% well then that that
person's an idiot yeah and for me to not
take for me to not look at criticism
even going back to the the relationship
with my dad the criticism he would give
me I would you know try to subjectively
look at as best as I could in and I can
look at some of this criticism and it
does one or two things for me it either
makes me say oh you know what they have
a point
I should XY and Z or it makes me look at
myself and say oh you know what no I'm
really really secure with who I am and
the way that I'm living my life and I
don't agree where where their
perspective is coming from with that
criticism so it strengthens who it
either helps me be a better person or it
will strengthen who who I already am
with with criticism yeah when it comes
to discharge when it comes to
unsolicited discharge that stuff I can
easily look at and and just kind of
compartmentalize it be like oh like that
person is a troll well especially
anything online because like people they
behave totally different online yes
there are different people that online
than they are in real life and so yeah
absolutely the different the different
formats there we go through so so when
you talk about this discharge the thing
that I think about is you say it's easy
for you to compartmentalize it I think
for most people and for us until we you
and I have been criticized so frequently
so much it's like up to and including
death threats it hurt yeah it hurt up
until about midway through 2014 I
finally started to like just be able to
compartmentalize it but what and that's
because I think we
some calluses along the way yeah but but
when I talk about seeking feedback from
trust of people and then avoiding
criticism from they say errs because it
it really I think it clutters our lives
if we're just getting the that discharge
right yeah and so so here's the thing I
said in the essay whenever you create
something meaningful you will be
critiqued and I would say oh yeah to
Riley whenever you do something
meaningful if you're simplifying your
life and you find meaning that if you're
getting rid of debt if you're trying to
make some sort of change you were going
to be critiqued there's no doubt about
whatever you stand for something and
people in your life are not standing for
the same thing they want to point out
how you're really not standing for that
I'm not standing for that and you're
really not standing for it either and
here's why you're not a real minimalist
you own underwear or whatever right in
fact I've got some examples here that I
pulled these from our YouTube comments
recently and so I've what I said is no
matter how close to perfect your
creation is or no matter how close to
perfect your life is right no matter how
close the perfect it is you will be
judged and so here are some some recent
comments I know and I'll tell you what I
did with them in a second the lighting
in your on your podcast looks creepy
ladies this video is stupid and they
spelled stupid st oh oh PID yeah that's
so funny and someone actually commented
don't quit your day job and so you know
what if we met those three people in
person they wouldn't dare say that to
our face right I I agree with and that's
that to me that's how I can cart
mentalize it it's because well just with
the example the person who spelled
stupid sto Oh PID they obviously don't
even take their own comment seriously
exactly but but here's the thing I and I
think that translates to Riley's
question here I think when we get so
comfortable with someone sometimes we
accidentally say some of these things
that are hurtful and we don't realize
that they're hurtful they're just flip
it these are really flippant calm
yeah and we're really close to someone
like parents or close family members
sometimes we accidentally say things
that's the exception your family they
will say that stuff to you right it's
your face yeah yeah which it does hurt
and so that's why I this this this stood
out with me and Riley so here's what
I'll say to Riley from the essay most
criticism is merely an unsolicited
discharge of personal preference and
because you didn't ask for it you aren't
required to respond you know I didn't
respond to these people know this video
isn't stupid but know the lighting see
what we're trying to do it I don't care
right I don't have a day job should I
get one yeah what day job do you
recommend I get and so so so you aren't
required to respond in fact it's best
not to clap back instead click delete or
mute or block and move on to the next
creation so that's exactly what I did
with with these I I block these people
I'll never see their comments ever again
right and here's the thing I think you
may not be able to block them but you
can delete or mute and sometimes that
requires the leverage you have with your
parents with your family members is
creating some distance from them if
they're behaving in a way that is
unsupportive then you don't have to
accept that you can walk away it doesn't
mean it doesn't mean you go to the
extreme right away if well I've had a
funeral for oh you said one bad thing
about me this relationship is dead yeah
it's not about that it's about oh okay
pointing out hey you know what you just
said right there I feel like that's
really not supportive yeah and I'd
appreciate if you would support me
because I care about you and I think you
care about me just to go back to your
point of because yet you're not gonna
end a relationship over one criticism or
one negative interaction and there
really isn't a number of how many
interactions you have to have before you
end a relationship but it just made me
think the the when I know to end a
relationship is when I feel tormented
when I feel like I've done everything I
can to save a relationship and I still
feel tormented and I have been putting
in that us box and I've been putting in
that us box and and and the other person
has not put anything in that us box and
if anything they've been taking from it
like that is where I think is where you
end the relationship
Riley you are not at this point you're
20 years old yeah you are you've got a
so funny man because when I was 20 I
would say the same stuff like man I'm
getting older and like people just you
know 37 year olds like me would laugh at
laugh at myself and be like haha you
think you're getting older you're 20
years old
but so so you know I'm not I'm not
undermining the fact that Riley is
getting older but Riley you're super
young and I'll tell you it took my mom
about five years before she finally came
around and she is so supportive now and
I'd never thought it was gonna happen
the hope was there but the expectation
of getting a hundred percent support
from my mom it was it was not there now
luckily that relationship did come full
circle and you know I've told the story
before I'll tell it again real quick but
like the moment I realize like oh my god
like my mom she accepts me and she is
supporting me it's when she was visiting
Mariah and I am Montana and it was the
first time she had ever come out there
Mariah and I had just moved into a new
place I picked her up from the airport
bring her back to my house she opens up
her suitcase and the first thing she
pulls out is like this like a vase and
some candles and some other stuff and
she's like hey I got you a present and
like in my head I'm like all right Ryan
don't be a jerk
don't project my own insecurities about
having things that I don't need yeah so
I didn't say anything I just you know
let her talk and she was like here are
some things I love you I'm proud of you
I am really proud of the relationship
you've built with Mariah this is a
beautiful place and I just wanted to
show you my appreciation
if this doesn't fit in your life then
please go find a good home for it please
give it away to someone that who is
gonna use it and it was in that moment I
was like oh my god like breakthrough
yeah it took five years yeah they get
that breakthrough so Riley um so that on
the other on the other side of the
spectrum with my mom I showed support
went way out of my way to appreciate her
to accept her to love her to respect her
I did everything I could and it paid off
after five years so Riley do the same
thing with your parents show them
support show them love show them respect
go
out of your way to have these
conversations with them about how you
need respect see when when we when when
any of us demand respect we first must
ask the question have we shown respect
right and if if that is not the case
then you must show respect before you
gain respect can't demand or connect
that's not how respect works it's not
how it works and her question was can
you how can how can I help them
understand that I want to be accepted
and that reminded me of this other essay
that we wrote called understanding
others I'm certainly not gonna read this
whole thing because it's a long one but
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
but there's this acronym in there ta ra
that you've heard us talk about before
and it's it's really the path to our
understanding other people and so all in
respects one of those but Riley if you
want them to accept you that is like
that's after the first step its
tolerance first first you have to find a
way they can tolerate your lifestyle so
are they doing that
are you tolerating them as well and then
it gets toward acceptance and we we talk
about the steps on sort of getting past
tolerance because it starts there but
tolerance is a really weak virtue if you
just tolerate someone imagine if you're
you're living with Mariah I mean you
live with Mariah now but you all just
tolerated each other God that would be a
miserable existence but it is necessary
to have the tolerance first before you
can get to the acceptance of well she's
different yet their own preferences her
own desires her own interests and then
beyond that a huge leap to the third
step is respect the ARA Tara you know
it's good well in the last one is
appreciation and that is the huge leap
eventually I think you can get to a
point Riley where you appreciate them
for who they are warts and all realizing
that their life is different from yours
yeah and that's okay in fact that's what
makes life beautiful or all these
differences because what what's the
alternative that we're all exactly the
same yeah well then there's nothing to
appreciate anyway yeah I was just gonna
say when it comes to that appreciation
piece of it man it's not like so with
Mariah as an example like yeah she has
more things than I than I have I don't
know the number of things I just
know that there are a lot of things
around the house I'm like oh like that's
not mine that's my eyes and it's not
that I appreciate the fact that she
collects more things but what I do
appreciate is the love the kindness the
respect that Mariah shows this
relationship and I also appreciate
everything she does for our relationship
I mean the the way that um she's just
like your stereo typical loves to cook
and loves to take care of the house and
loves to like just really create a
beautiful environment for us to live in
you have to take care of the relation
she does and I appreciate that so much
that for me to look at her stuff and say
you know what I know that you got more
stuff than me but it's cool i love you
so much and like everything you do for
this relationship i appreciate so much
if if it if it if it helps her if it
shows her the appreciation by me letting
go of my own insecurities and my own
idiosyncrasies for her for her I want to
say her well-being but it's more than
her well-being but her preferences yeah
I'm sure Matt does this with with
Natalie which by the way Matt just got
engaged oh my god yeah Congrats man
Thalia that's right but and he I mean
with Natalie I mean I know she's
definitely not a minimalist you did a
video on your YouTube channel about
living with your non minimalist
girlfriend your non minimalist fiance
you have to like update the title right
you just go in like do voiceovers like
to inject the word fiance but I mean she
showed up to dodge ball last week I
could tell she was probably wearing a
brand new outfit this at USA because it
was a fourth of July no I can tell like
Matt would never show up wearing the USA
tank top or whatever put like it's that
a pretty and the cool thing is like I
actually saw you appreciated that like
you've got this little Australian woman
who shows up at our dodgeball league
like being the most American fourth of
July person there
and it was pretty great so you're able
to appreciate these idiosyncrasies in a
way when you step back from yourself and
realize hey I'm not subtle up Cystic I'm
not the center of the universe
right I could appreciate these other
things too and that's okay yeah yeah
yeah and I guess what I'm trying to get
at too is like again it's not like I
appreciate head-on I look at Mariah's
collection of things and I head on I go
you know what I've learned to appreciate
her collection of things know what what
I have learned to do is by showing her
that I accept accept her idiosyncrasies
that is in turn showing her how much I
appreciate the relationship you you
appreciate her as a whole even if even
if you don't like every single trinket
you